welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
promises to shed light on Rocket Raccoon
whom James Gunn is called the secret
protagonist of the series so in this
video I'm gonna do a character breakdown
to shine a spotlight on this trash Panda
and break down at least I don't know 20
key facts about this guy that we don't
talk about enough and make a case for
why he really is the secret protagonist
they're really not that secret leader of
this franchise and why we shouldn't get
our faces scratched up or calling him a
Rocket Raccoon even though there's still
a lot about him we don't know you don't
know anything about me loser okay so in
the MCU we first meet Rocket in
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 on the
planet xandar and right off the bat this
guy clearly hates humanoids
what a bunch of losers all of them in a
big hurry to get from something stupid
to nothing at all and as explored and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 don't
worry no spoilers in this video this
hatred comes from a backstory with the
high evolutionary Herbert Windham who
cruelly experiment on this patient 89p13
along with others like Lila floor
antiques rocket is actually one of the
most sensitive characters in the MCU
forming bonds despite himself and
feeling lost more deeply because of
everything he suffered in this past the
Guardians of the Galaxy Trilogy is
Rocket's hero's journey Gunn has said
volume 1 is about the mother Vol 2's
about the father and volume 3 is about
the self and that self is very much
rocket and his pain he spends most of
his time in the MCU in denial that he's
a raccoon and the running joke is that
no one quite knows what he is so I ain't
about to be brought down by a tree in a
talking raccoon can I bet your puppy
it is adorable hey there rat rabbit is
correct and clearly the smartest among
you that's how eyesight works you stupid
raccoon don't call me a raccoon I'm
sorry I took it too far
I meant trash Panda honestly into this
exact second I thought you were
Build-A-Bear maybe I am even that
triangle face monkey there and while
this is played for humor it seems like
rocket doesn't find this very funny keep
calling me Vermin tough guys he thinks
of some stupid thing he does well I
didn't ask to get made I didn't ask to
be torn apart and put back together over
and over and turned into some some
little monster and so this bitterness
toward other bipedal humanoids is where
we find rocket and xandar in volume one
having teamed up with Groot as a bounty
hunter Duo trying to capture Peter Quill
for yondu and get interested and
processed by the Nova Corps where we get
a fascinating rap sheet for the
character subject
89p13 calls itself rocket the result of
illegal genetic and cybernetic
experiments on a lower life form and
let's zoom in enhance on this we see
subject 89p13 Alias rocket origin half
World which is also his origin of the
comics where animal-like test subjects
live his length is listed as 144
microbials height 168 grets legs to arms
too and then we see enhancements
cybernetic skeletal structure enhanced
phalange and metacarpal bones
genetically augmented cerebral cortex so
this explains why he's so smart and how
we can also take so much physical abuse
because of his cybernetic skeleton he's
kind of like a rocket version of
Wolverine ain't no thing like me except
me but back to the screen we see
Associates Groot and Lila Lila of course
is Rocket's Usher like soul mate from
the comics who are going to meet in
Guardians volume 3 we also see his
criminal record 13 counts of theft 22
counts of escape from incarceration
seven counts of mercenary activity 15
counts of arson and then we get a
warning tendency to bite hey there's a
lot of this on this shirt I'm wearing
you can actually get this at
nerdright.shop by the way but this
tendency to bite is hilarious because
earlier when we saw Gamora bite him he
said fighting that's not fair and also
in Guardians Volume 2 when mantis pets
him he bites her which makes Drax crack
up rocket also brings up his prison
escape record later with a lot of Pride
I ain't gonna be here long I've escaped
22 prisons this one's no different which
brings up perhaps the most impressive
maneuver in the entire volume 1 film The
Way rocket escapes from the Kiln so by
the way we gotta up that escape number
to 23. Rocket details his complicated
plan which requires many things
including I need his prosthetic leg but
it turns out not really oh I was just
kidding about the leg I just need these
two things what no I thought it'd be
funny wasn't funny but this is very
important to Rocket it actually kicks
off a running bit about rocket being
obsessed with stealing fake Limbs and
parts
no seriously I need it it's important to
me but leave the eye here what he's
gonna wake up tomorrow
[Music]
where is
[Applause]
silences what's it look like some jerk
lost a bet with me in contraxia okay how
much for the arm
I'll get that off and yeah he totally
does get this arm as a Christmas present
in the guardian's holiday special
Christmas but back in boy one during the
kill and Escape he inverts the gravity
outside the guard booth like a Superman
2 Fortress a Solitude move and then uses
the security drones to tote the booth
out of there which is pure Brilliance
and it showed how inventive and
improvisational that genetically
augmented cerebral cortex is the guy can
make a last minute Escape out of a box
of scraps rather than Tony Stark's doing
it once rocket does it again and again
and again pretty much every time we see
him in the MCU he's also super heroic
just watch volume one the guy is the
unabashed hero of the story he's ready
to save Peter from The ravagers he
blasts a hole in the dark Aster ship so
the others can get in he shoots down
necro craft over water on xandar so they
don't crash into civilians xandarian
said he started this movie talking
about and then he kamikazes the warship
to bring it down and when his best
friend sacrifices himself we see the
inner Humanity of this trash Panda idiot
Groot sacrifice in this moment is likely
what inspires rocket to step up and join
in with the rest of the team as they
take over the power Stone we see him
reach up his little paw to take tracks
his hand remember he started this movie
hunting quill for money and is ready to
sacrifice him for as we heard earlier
the only friends we ever had and as they
defeat Ronan we get this moment where
rocket is cradling a stick from Groot
and Drax puts his hand on his head to
pet him in rocket who normally hates
anytime anyone does this tense is up but
gives in and allows himself to be
comforted as you can see by his tail
relaxing but he replants the Groot stick
and at the end of the movie we get baby
groot's groot's son music has always
been such an important part of the
Guardians of the Galaxy films and nerd
Riot's new awesome mix merch collection
has taken that idea and run with it they
have matched up iconic album art with
the Guardians themselves it's the
perfect gear to wear opening weekend or
while rocking out in your daily life
never mind whether or not you grew up on
grunge you could get grunge Groot but if
all the stars have been feeling more
like Ziggy Stardust then the Ziggy
Star-Lord T might be what you need if
you like Dark Side of the Moon then
you'll love this dark side of the Galaxy
T I mean while I'm rocking my all-time
favorite Rock album Rumors by Fleetwood
Mac cause I can never make the chain and
I'm wearing this rumors inspired
ravager's shirt highly recommend you
grab one shopping at nerd Riot is one of
the best ways to support our Channel and
in addition to tons more Guardians merch
you can find merch inspired by the MCU
Star Wars DC all your favorite fandoms
to get your hands on the merch you need
head to nerd riot.shop today join the
riot over at nerdriot.shop and Guardians
Volume 2 rocket is just as stubborn and
dickish and Reckless as ever but we see
even more that vulnerability Underneath
It All it's as if the more or he opens
himself up to love with this found
family the more he has to offset that in
this case by pointlessly stealing the
anilax batteries that lead to the
Guardians being pursued by Aisha and The
Sovereign a problem that is still
chasing them in volume 3 without a
warlock the Guardians meet ego Will's
evil dad and Aisha sends the ravagers
after them rocket is so sad when Peter
chooses to split the party with some of
them going to ego's planet and some of
them staying behind he's probably
feeling separation anxiety like a puppy
when he's left home alone can I pet your
puppy it is adorable yes
and notice how while the others leave
rocket repairs the ship with the spray
3D printer which gun has tweeted is a
special technology that takes an insane
amount of focus and detail orientation
to use showing how rocket has in the
past taken that time to map out a
perfect layout of the ship he never
wants it to change he is obsessed with
the details and then after this he lays
the perfect trap for the ravagers
he anticipated the ravager is coming and
he lured them in by humming Glen
Campbell's Southern Knights through the
radio to make them think he was on the
ship but nope he hilariously bounces
them around with these gravity snares
rocket bonds with yondu in this movie on
the ravager ship and yondu gives us our
first hint to the high evolutionary's
backstory in volume three I know them
scientists what made you never gave a
rat's ass about you a super important
line because not only does it show that
yandu knows who the high evolutionary
was and everything the high evolutionary
does is pretty publicly known in the
galaxy and that everyone just kind of
looks the other way for these two
characters yondu paints he and Rocket as
parallel figures they steal they don't
need they're short-tempered what kind of
a pair are we and so when yandu
sacrifices himself in a third Act of
this movie we see how it really takes a
toll on rocket I'm sorry
I can only afford to lose one friend
today and during yondu's funeral rocket
slips up and conflates yandu's flaws
with his own he didn't chase him away
even though he yelled at him I was
always mean
and he stole batteries he didn't need
bringing this is volume two final shot
with Cat Stevens I know I have to go on
Rocket's tear Street face in particular
knowing how hard it is for rocket to
lose Guardians makes it even more
painful when he loses Groot in Infinity
War
no no no no no by the way James gun
later confirmed that that final I am
Groot translated to Daddy and you know
how rocket heard that loud and clear in
Avengers end game Rocket is reunited
with nebula and there's a moment where
he Pats nebula's hand again a big
gesture for him since the guy isn't big
on physical contact but still they grasp
hands together in their grief remember
while the other Guardians were dusted
these two stayed on Earth for five years
during the blip you could say they have
the most history together and so it
makes sense to see them rise up in this
leadership status in volume 3 but
throughout end game Rocket wears Peter's
Red Scarf just another indicator of how
much he loves and misses him rocket ends
up helping out with a Time Heist going
to Asgard with Thor who is a mess in
this movie much to Rockets discuss
you think you're the only one who lost
people what do you think we're doing
here I lost the only family I ever had
quill group Drax the chick with the
antenna all gone and when they finally
succeeded getting everyone back who
snapped away we see how unwilling rocket
is to lose that family again when he
Shields Groot with his body during the
final battle in Thanos is onslaught
rocket makes brief appearances in Thor
love and Thunder and I am Groot fighting
alongside Thor on various planets
including ninjagar and being one
Guardian other than Baby Groot to appear
in I am Groot receiving groot's magnum
opus art project why are you handing me
this what is this what trash Oh
this is very nice
then we gotta get this Frame put up at
the top of the fridge
I can't stay mad at you can I and
finally he shows up in the Guardians
holiday special after the Guardians have
bought nowhere from The Collector rocket
works with Cosmo the space dog who fixed
some damage done by the Power Stone in
the past or maybe by Thanos sacking this
place to get the reality Stone Cosmo
what uses telekinesis if you can't even
aim and we see him get pissed at Kevin
Bacon dude calm down
raccoon I'll kill you don't ever
follow me yeah remember he wasn't
offended before he knew what a raccoon
was but now that he knows anytime anyone
calls him a raccoon he goes off it is
his biggest trigger and so from this
biographical breakdown what do we know
about rocket on the eve of volume three
well tragic backstory as an experiment
by the high evolutionary experiments
that based on yondu knowing it was
scientists who made him were publicly
known to many in the Galaxy rocket has a
bitterness toward normal humanoid
society and an appreciation for quote
unquote monsters and broken things he's
all bark and all bites But ultimately a
big softy and most importantly truly one
of the smartest engineering brains in
the MCU hey thanks for watching this
character breakdown of Rocket you can
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive where this Friday May 5th at noon
Eastern I'll be doing a live stream q a
and live breakdown of volume three you
can support this growing Network by
grabbing something from our merch store
nerd Riot that shot support new rock
stars on YouTube and on all social
platforms
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]